well nobody listens when you're yelling
you know make people - now I do I'm like
other being really loud right now when
we come back in when they're a little
calmer
you know so hopefully people are leaning
in to try to hear what's going on and
when they lean back out again hopefully
they have some stuff to think about my
name is Alicia Garza and I'm one of the
cofounders of black lives matter to say
all lives matter
in response to black people saying that
black lives matter it's actually saying
that black lives don't matter what's
important for you to know is that it's
only a threat to you if you believe that
black people should be inferior if you
believe that black people are living in
the conditions that they are because of
their own choices and decision we are
not just a movement that is focused on
police violence and police brutality the
reality is that for black people in this
country we have been plagued by a
pervasive and dominant system when we
look at issues of housing employment
education health care and healthcare
access black people are at the bottom of
those disparities over the last three
years we've grown from a hashtag to an
international organizing Network lots of
people think that organizing is being in
the streets with a bullhorn and turning
up and organizing is not really that at
all none of organizing is glamorous but
some of it is rewarding we can build a
world where all lives matter together if
we acknowledge the ways today in which
all lives don't matter